>>> THIS IS THE FINAL "PIERS
MORGAN LIVE."
AFTER THREE YEARS, TWO MONTHS,
11 DAYS AND OVER 1,000 SHOWS,
I'M DEPARTING TO SPEND MORE
TIME.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE MY TEAM AND
MY EXECUTIVE PRODUCER, MY
MANAGER WHO LANDED ME THIS
FASCINATING, UNPREDICTING,
CHALLENGING, BUT ENJOYABLE JOB.
WE WON SOME, WE LOST SOME, BUT
WE GAVE IT EVERYTHING WE HAD AND
I LOVED EVERY MINUTE, ALMOST
EVERY MINUTE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
WATCHING, EVEN THOUGH WHO
DISAGREE WITH ME.
OR FOUND MY ACCENT ANNOYING.
THE ISSUE OF GUN CONTROL HAS
BEEN A CONSISTENT AND OFTEN VERY
CONTROVERSIAL PART OF THIS SHOW.
AND I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING MORE
ABOUT THAT BEFORE I BUY OUT.
I'VE LIVED A WORD TO AMERICA FOR
MUCH OF THE PAST DECADE.
A LAND OF TRUE OPPORTUNITY THAT
AFFORDS ANYONE, EVEN BRITISH
LIKE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE DECENT,
HARDWORKING DEPENDABLE PEOPLE.
AS MY BROTHER, A BRITISH ARMY
COLONEL SAYS, YOU ALWAYS WANT AN
AMERICAN NEXT TO YOU IN THE
TRENCH WHEN THE GOING GETS
TOUGH.
BUT THAT'S WHERE GUNS BELONG, ON
THE BATTLEFIELD, FIGHTING FOR
DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM, NOT IN
THE HANDS OF CIVILIANS.
EACH DAY ON AVERAGE, 35 PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE MURDERED
WITH GUNS AND ANOTHER 50 KILL
THEMSELVES WITH GUNS AND 200
MORE ARE SHOT BUT SURVIVE.
THAT'S 100,000 PEOPLE A YEAR HIT
BY GUNFIRE IN AMERICA.
NOW, I ASSUME THAT AFTER 70
PEOPLE WERE SHOT IN A MOVIE
THEATER AND A FEW MONTHS LATER
20 FIRST GRADERS WERE MURDERED
WITH AN ASSAULT RIFLE IN AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT THE GUN
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY WOULD
CHANGE, BUT NOTHING HAPPENED.
THE GUN LOBBY HAS BULLIED THE
POLITICIANS INTO COWARDLY
SILENCE.
EVEN WHEN 20 YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
BLOWN AWAY IN THEIR CLASSROOMS.
THIS IS SHAMEFUL THAT HAS MADE
ME VERY ANGRY.
SO ANGRY IN FACT THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE CRITICIZING ME FOR
BEING TOO LOUD, OPINION ATED,
EVEN RUDE WHEN I DEBATED THE
ISSUE OF GUNS.
BUT I MAKE NO APOLOGIES FOR
THAT.
SO AS CHURCHILL SAID WHEN YOU
HAVE A POINT TO MAKE, USE A PILE
DRIVER, HIT IT, THEN AGAIN, THEN
A THIRD TIME.
MY POINT IS SIMPLE, MORE GUNS
DOESN'T MEAN LESS CRIME AS THE
NRA REPEATEDLY TRIES TO TELL
YOU.
IT MEANS MORE GUN VIOLENCE, MORE
DEATH AND MORE PROFIT FOR THE
GUN MANUFACTURERS.
THOSE WHO CLAIM IT'S
ANTI-AMERICAN, THE REVERSE IS
TRUE.
I AM SO PRO AMERICAN, I WANT
MORE OF YOU TO STAY ALIVE.
BUT I'VE GIVEN IT A TREMENDOUS
WHACK.
NOW IT'S DOWN TO YOU.
IT IS YOUR COUNTRY.
THESE ARE YOUR GUN LAWS.
AND THE SENSELESS SLAUGHTER WILL
ONLY END WHEN ENOUGH AMERICANS
STAND TOGETHER AND CRY, ENOUGH.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT DAY.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU ALL
AGAIN SOON.
THANK